was better yeah this is good before we
look silly now work does good now look
that it's not super post-apocalyptic
you're the artillery guys like the like
the spindle II but like kind of feral
manic crazy guy like that the guy
doesn't like the guy that's like the
little like Berserker that gets hell
like let out of a hatch yeah exactly
with you I has a secret weapon at some
point yeah she's like totally amoral
yeah legs you know kind of probably
probably like mildly cannibal yeah hey
welcome back welcome back we're back
we're doing a hammer gun it's our post
apocalypse episode there's even I'm just
gonna dismantle the illusion right yeah
it's just for sure just yet and and
we're back and thank you for for joining
us again for even more fury on the road
thanks for getting on yeah by jack
carroll McCarthy jack kerouac aarthi his
jack carroll on the the row shine on you
crazy the road Lou Diamond Phillips I
guess you this is word father yeah it's
just like you're running a magnetic
crossing magnetic poetry kids words you
pick up now focus don't quit dreams work
and language you always get languid
that's like the adjectives that always
comes out when those magnetic poetry
languid yeah I can languid a lot force
really maybe it's just because it's on
the fridge but yeah I wonder how often
people get eldritch eldritch yeah oh man
I don't know I don't know if my kid
hendra Eldridge is just like to go to
word for one song wants to like 8 HP
Lovecraft and be creepy it's this
elegant which room spooky room don't
name my kid Albert Eldridge Eldridge is
you do your homework
oh dammit eldritch I was too busy
playing about in the primordial ooze I
won't believe oh yes this turns in his
homework it's is growing tentacles yes
and and making some kind of stay awful
noise Julia's night Vale eldritch I'll
Richard jr. Eldridge jr. just listens
episodes knife and reads it HP left ribs
listening tonight feels just like oh
such a slice of life yeah it's like yeah
hashtag relatable when's a bay oh Carlos
yeah it's perfect hair cut welcome back
enjoy yet more dank ass man Matt's
discussion yep and see you at the deck
see what the day like a like the world's
fair yes at the bank see you at the day
at the dank summit one day while having
dates well I think I see ya um I want to
bring something up uh this I was talking
to it with a friend of ours you remember
grace right yeah yeah she um I saw her
she wants to know my thoughts on the
movie neither talk with her because I
just saw it last night as of this
recording huh um and she said something
that I thought was really cool and it's
like you know it's enough for us to guys
to draw on about the feminist text in
this movie but this is this is my friend
Grace's take um it felt so weird to
relate to something so out there um this
is she's referring to the scene where
they get back to furiosus clan to find
out this green place Oh where's all
these and it is like this this society
of these elderly matriarchs that are
still like perfectly capable in a fight
yeah and she finds out the green place
they pass through it's now a decrepit
stagnant swamp with still walking Creek
guys on it which were cool it's like I
love that that kind of surrealist touch
of this still walking circus Olay ish
guys
but grace is um when furiosa drops on
her knees after finding the green place
doesn't exist anymore it felt exactly
like when I become overwhelmed by
patriarchal society at every turn like
when I get hit on or when a guy expects
something for me or says something
sexist or woman is hurt or I see Men's
Rights [ __ ] ah it's like that moment
furiosa is going back to the one place
that seems safe for women and when she
gets there it's gone and there's no
escape and the whole world is just run
by nasty [ __ ] yeah nasty anti-female
ship yeah damn yeah I never thought
about that that's well that's that's
like date again I don't entirely agree
that they make her into like fully stoic
and stuff because it's like there are
moments like that words like they're
very emotive yeah and that's you know
that's a scene that's easy to make silly
to in it yeah did not come across this
and it fell barriers because it's like
you know character drops their knees and
curses in in agony it's like you know
it's a stock thing but I I thought it
was very I thought it was earned yeah
yeah it's not it's not this is people
yet try to do that moment without really
earning it and this this they earned and
I like to call that it's like not only
is my home gone all hope is literally
gone we went looking for escape there is
none anymore well it's almost worse you
know it's it's it's that much more of a
sort of a stab when it's like not only
is it not there you've already went
through it like like you know you you
see movies occasionally where it what
it's like Oh your goal isn't really
there it's not real or an order no and
by what is further down the line this is
like oh [ __ ] we were already that we
should have been there already you saw
it like it we saw it and it you got
stuck there and it sucked yeah you spent
a good amount of time in the ruin of of
your salvation you know like that is so
destroyed you didn't even see it as as
ruins you saw it is just nothing yeah
yeah you didn't think twice about other
than the annoyance of being there you
know getting held up in the mud but
that's interesting
Yeah right yeah what it's phuc jeans
yeah [ __ ] boys [ __ ] way yeah um so if I
well and I mean you know furious into
like I like the nuances of her
performance cuz there were moments like
I thought she played that with a lot of
emotion and a lot of investment yeah cuz
they're like all the characters come out
through these little nuances yeah sounds
like that it's not dialogue heavy but
it's like you can tell how much she
cares in about stuff like you know you
can tell how much there's little moments
where like her eyes are watering over
things and it's just like you feel that
like sometimes the difference between
masculinity and just being tough is
sometimes like having to soldier when
you're just overwhelmed you know and I
thought they communicated that in her
alot it's like she just has a purpose
and it's overwhelming and awful but you
just gotta keep moving on you know
Leonard I'm gonna sort of tangent
tangent I'm um so oh and one thing um
everyone is founded on this and a little
bit one thing that I thought was really
great about as um as far as you know
just showing the you know the valuing of
you know female persons throughout the
movie versus not though the wet nurses
ha at the beginning there's immortan joe
has this disturbing disturbing wet-nurse
private farm oh we're just these farming
Mars milk farming human breast milk just
to keep his stock of airs supplied and
to keep his his nascent newborn war boys
fed it's like well and that's also
probably like I gotta imagine at least
it's the most disturbing to humanizing
thing Evers like you have these these
like these women that are being overfed
and
forced to just stay completely
stationary and sedentary and just having
these forever pumps attached to them
they are literally human chattel their
dairy cows it's like the most nasty
dehumanizing thing and it's like I think
the implication is when the wives are no
longer fertile that's where they go oh
they go to become become farmed
furniture and it's like they like that
made my skin crawl when I saw that and
what was brilliant like that also ties
into the world because like cuz rictus
erectus comes up and he jus like drinks
some yeah and I gotta imagine like you
know they say yeah cuz they're all
diseased and they're all you know kind
of sickly and gross and I gotta imagine
that he probably has at least cuz
Richter's erectus is his son yeah is
most isn't is bull dislike most put
together son you know whoever is in
immortan joe circle not even just the
newborns but I've got imagine like
they're all probably chugging breast
milk you're hoping to get some of those
nutrients back or something yeah hoping
to know to stop being so sickly like it
is a terrible outcome but it's one that
sort of seems like it would happen in
that version of society it's like we got
to get some vitamins somewhere man yeah
you know and that's kind of in that ties
into the whole idea of like you know
like they ask you know who killed the
world so it's like you have these shitty
these shitty men that are destroying
everything but it's like there's no they
don't know how to create anything that's
nourishing or new or nurturing or
anything like that so they have to
dehumanize women that can actually like
produce nutrition and and put them
through hell and abuse them in order to
like kind of suck that out of them well
and it's like you know is the best
carrot like the characters who get the
most done in this movie are the most
effective and who are the most
formidable or you know it's like if you
look at your heroes and stuff it's like
you have max and you have furio's and
you have the y and they all sort of they
all kind of have this scale of
masculinity and femininity where is like
immortan joe and his war but like
they're all this sort of like it's all
it's pure testosterone masculine like
it's it's all like
macho and wasteful it's like in a world
where gas is scarce they sure waste a
lot of yeah but I I get that they're
wasting a lot of it because it's about
pageant rants about it yeah and they
have I mean the fact that they have to
have a guy blasting heavy metal yeah and
shredding hot licks while they ride into
battle because like dumbasses you're
killing yourselves and people yeah
you're killing people as well as
yourselves and you're making this into a
party yeah you love this [ __ ] like it's
like you you [ __ ] idiots yeah you do
you guys are morons and you're wasting
so much in the process it's a furthering
your who don't understand you're not
living in post-scarcity anymore you're
living in New scarcity you don't have
gas to waste yeah it's like even if you
have gas town like eventually you're
gonna have to fight you're gonna run out
of gas town like yeah maybe the bullet
farm will keep going but you're gonna
need guzzoline somewhere else it looks
like the bullet farm you can you know
you can have an ammo pressing thing and
you can reload around but doesn't seem
like you're short on metal so much you
know huh yeah that's like but what I
what I liked about the the even the the
poor wet nurses they had a her Oh turn
at the end they are the people that
opened the gazing day you gave water
again everyone yeah it's like at long
last these these and that and that goes
back to like you know the whole
philosophy of like toxic masculinity and
patriarchal society there's this nasty
gross devaluing of mother figures is
like wanting to devalue motherhood and
it's like here you have these women debt
or defined by motherly capabilities and
now it's what they do with that freeze
everyone yeah well it's almost like this
it is the it's similar because they're
they're they're giving some sort of
life-giving you know it looks certain
few people but in you know it's like the
flip side of that it's like here's the
good version of that yeah here's the non
terrible here's the non terrible I'm
strapped to it to an electric chair
that's draining me version of it oh yeah
so um in some good movie yeah well n I
mean you know beyond beyond the more
challenging subtext it's like there's I
just there's so many little nuances I
appreciate its like it's it's amazing
what happens when you you just treat
characters like and this isn't even men
and one thing Street characters like
people because there are so many little
moments where it's like Max is sort of
thrust into this situation and I enjoy
that it's like in that first scene he
puts up a good fight but when he's on
that hook that's the other one they
catch him Leia he's not Superman and
then it's like you have these great
little moment isn't up until the end of
the first act he's just strapped to a
[ __ ] car yeah exactly i think was
like hating every minute of it and it's
the little thing it's like when slit
throws that spear right past his face he
turns around and says something's like
that's my face like you know and that
whole thing with the with the muzzle he
just you can tell how annoyed just
physically it's a physically annoying
thing to have a face and it's just like
it's a real it's just those real
character bits it's like in the fact
that Furioso was able to compete them
will use that is that you want to get
that off your face right yeah it's like
how am I gonna get this kind of move I
know you want that thing off your face
here now we can work together and it's
brilliant because just like Max under
and it's like it shows really clearly
max kind of understands at the very
least of a sample of what he understands
a sample of what the wives were going
through he is muzzled like a dog so he
is able to throw in his lot with the
people who have had their freedom
stripped from them yeah cuz even they
treat him like they so you know what
they refer to him as but they they crazy
Schmidt who eats laga no no before that
because it's something the like one of
the war boys calls him or something
before the black bag it's um it's
something something about a wild whoa oh
yeah nuts calls in like a crazy guy and
you know it's like he's crazy blood is
gonna keep me yeah it's like battle they
establish him as like subhuman and
there's decided from the get-go so it's
like you know you get that sort of
relation point but also it's like you
know max is Max's seems like you know
he's still damaged but he's one of the
good one
in this society because you can tell
like he's got a sick car but it's more
out of necessity than like you know it's
like he he's not he hasn't drunk the
kool-aid of this you know mad future
world because any other movies to you
know like a lot of the people in this
version of the world are kind of nuts
yeah kind of nutty and I want to know
how exactly that works because like Mad
Max in the original movie like he was a
cop before everything fell apart it
wasn't think it's been the longest since
I've seen that yeah and I think doesn't
the original movie kind of start at the
tail end of society yeah so it's like
people wouldn't really crazy really fast
yeah they built a lot of cars really
fast what I love that little detail to
or where they see the satellite she's
like back then everybody had a show yeah
you know and so yeah you sort of wonder
how many years in the future is this
because it happy that like and it's like
you don't you don't get super super
concerned with that well in this this
movie is sort of in a nebulous space
it's a Mad Max adventure and then it
doesn't need to necessarily mind is
something I want to say I wanted one of
the older women to survive it they did
not know more the older age did one but
a couple of the mothers do survive which
mothers so from the the first mother the
the group with the motorcycles some of
them survived because when they get up
on the lift I don't I don't think I saw
any of them yeah they're they're a
couple of their at least a couple okay
it's like I didn't notice that my fated
to do okay because it was like it didn't
feel ya I'm glad that happened does it
didn't feel right to me for all the
first mothers to be gone yeah yeah they
do at least a couple of dude okay well
thanks one of the other ones and yeah
yeah so there cuz they're in the car
Thea it's not as apparent on the looking
upward shots when they're actually
lifting them but when they get to the
platform you see them yeah okay I'll
have to look for like I saw this movie
and I'm glad I did we saw with would you
catch more stuff a second time right
yeah we saw with doreen right so Doreen
she was psyched to see this movie she
loves everything post-apocalyptic and
everything tom party oh yeah so it's
like except for Bronson she wasn't so
into Bronson really yeah I gotta see
both I
Branson um but so it's like we saw it
with Doreen and or do you want to see it
when I was worth every [ __ ] penny 20
bucks a ticket to see it in like the AMC
plus thing big leather reclining chair
yeah 3d and the 3d wasn't a huge deal we
didn't need the 3d but yeah cool I'm i
go i might check out a 4 DX or something
yeah but it was like sitting in the
leather recliner rumbling with the with
the sound effects it was like I was
liquefied at the a movie uh I was it was
like I was put into I was shaking like a
[ __ ] martini yeah and when I got out
I was I wanted to not stir nuts when I
got out it was like I was put in a
high-speed centrifuge all my fluids were
drained out of me i was in a sweat did
you poop no i was just in a sweat okay i
was just moist and i wanted to beat the
[ __ ] out of the patriarchy with my face
yeah I think I want to I wanted to beat
patriarchy with my face in the United
States I think that should be on every
poster yeah just be patriarch you bring
patriarchy was your face in the United
States hey man thanks Australia yeah
thanks us really for help I know and
nambia for what is this is shot they
will give a shot nambia namibia maybe
and then maybe a [ __ ] i always get that
clumsy I my apologies to the proud
nation of Namibia but yeah I know like I
just I just love that it's like because
some people complain about like oh you
know the way you played Max and I mean
I'm always on on board with like if
you're gonna have somebody else take
over a role they should make it their
own and I just really like how again
just those little just max looks really
uncomfortable yes I'm like he looks like
and again it's like this is a world
where like diplomacy and talking is not
the first mode of communication so like
everyone is a little bit awkward and Max
is a little bit awkward and kind of like
it's also easy a guy who's how he's
having all those flashbacks to his dead
daughter that boy got PTSD yeah like
that are really disturbing so it's like
Tom Hardy plays him like an awkwardly
kind of mentally fractured guy it's not
this thing's works like oh I'm having
spooky flashbacks that are making me
have nightmares and and cool nightmares
me and making it hard to sleep and I
just like act weary but then go back to
being a hardass it's like no he's really
kind of jittery in a little like on edge
at all times yeah it's like all the
characters just remain themselves
through everything yeah it's like he's
hyper vigilant yeah by eez he's got real
real PTSD not movie PTSD yeah exactly I
also didn't catch the first time that
that arrow actually goes into his head
yeah i saw that because always like for
a second i was like oh his hand is kind
of stuck there yeah like he gotta pull
that [ __ ] yeah like i was like oh I saw
him struggle with those like oh it's
pinned to his skull and then he pulls
out and that I see the little puncture
wounds like that's awesome one even that
they brought that back cuz they're there
that that little vision a couple times
she'll throw the hand up that hill go
like that yeah and it's like that came
up a couple times with that by roy shade
off yeah it's just like the little
detention two little details like that
little payoffs and things and just like
the whole construction i just like i
haven't seen a movie quite like that or
I was like enthralled and and and my
expectations were like exceeded cuz I
talked about this on my review is like I
don't get excel like getting excited
about movies as a scary thing to me now
it's like I don't let myself do it you
know it's there are only two movies in
recent memory that I allowed myself to
get as excited as I wanted to be for ya
and that was World's End and that was
mad Max and both those movies exceeded
my excitement you know it's like not
only it's like on the one hand it's just
a really well-crafted action movie with
the right approach this movie seems like
it was made by somebody who is really on
top of the game of making an action
movie but has not seen any action movie
that's out today and I mean that in the
best way it's like it's somebody that
does not care about what's the hot new
trobe does not care about what what is
standard for everyone else it's just
like this is what I want to make and
this how I want to play it and this is
what's going to be most effective yeah
exactly one and I mean you to hear him
talk about action cinema I mean this is
a guy it seems like he really
understands actions
anima and and and takes that to mean he
also understands Lorenzo's oil cinnamon
he does he'd understand Lorenzo's oil
cinema and you know extraordinary pigs
Aman ya and dance and ask penguins you
but like but but I think in a couple of
the sort of just little review capsule
uh interview capsules I've read with him
you know he touches on that idea of like
action cinema is not just set pieces
it's telling a story through action like
everything is based in the action and
thus you know it's short on dialogue
because it's heavy on visual yeah you
know storytelling it tells the story
with with physicality and I think that
nothing is passive in this world and I
think that's actually kind of brilliant
it's like you know people are people try
and have their philosophy on the rules
of the road for for action cinema road
no pun intended but it there's there's
almost like when people talk about how
in video games there's this whole
problem of love like Ludo narrative
dissonance where the story bits are over
here and the gameplay bits are over here
and it's almost like you know the story
in the gameplay are telling two
different messages and I feel like
action cinema like action movies have
that issue to where it's like the story
business here yeah ten minutes later the
action business here and it's 10 minutes
of story 15 minutes of action tenants to
sort of 25 minutes of action five
minutes story at the very end it's like
that doesn't work you have to have your
story you have to have quiet moments to
you know make sure that you have the
proper melody for your action but you
have to if you're gonna make an action
movie you have to tell the story in the
action the narrative in the action
cannot be segregated yeah it's almost it
sounds like the difference you're in an
operative musical it's like if you're
gonna make it like a true action we
ought to it's like an opera one way or
another all is some yeah either whether
or not it's an aria or whatever you call
the the singing dialogue yeah and then
in a musical you know and I like these
goes maybe this is bad metaphor but it's
like in a musical there are scenes there
is speaking and then we take a break and
sing a song about that theme
yeah and I feel like like a great action
movie sort of is that opera where it's
like there's always some kind of action
at hand and it's all advancing the story
is still unfolding cause and effect is
still there an action movie is a story
told with action not a story told in
between action yeah exactly and so many
I feel like there's a problem with
action movies now in big spectacle
movies now because it's like along the
way people caught wind after so many
roland emmerich and Michael Bay movies
were like uh you know action movies are
just so dumb and now like we have this
weird pseudo thing where movies take
breaks now to try and convince you
they're kind of smart and to try and
kind of have character moments to make
us care and then they get back to having
fun again yeah it's like the action is
like you know action movies are like
I'll be it's almost like it's always
like an action your standard action mood
today is almost like a school day works
like you know half an hour of class
15-minute fun break yeah half an hour of
class you know here now hopeful minutes
between between so you can like chill
out yeah I have an hour class you know
20 minutes for lunch yeah and it's like
that doesn't work you know hour for
lunch is like that doesn't work yes it's
like you gotta an action movie it's like
the action you're gonna tell a story in
which action is prominent the action
should be intertwined with the story
it's like the action should all be for a
going and make sense no no should be
mirrored it's like when people tell like
before going into the movie finally and
people were saying psycho you know the
whole movie is just one long cartridge I
was like how does that work and then I
saw it was like yeah you know it's
multiple car chases it's multiple
distinct car chases they're not always
being actively pursue their able to
shake off their pursuers at moments but
it's like no it's it really is the story
is the pursuit yeah like when people say
oh it's a chase movie it's like you
think it's going to be idiotic it's like
no this is a movie where people are
being constantly pursued for the most
part until they turn everything around
but it's like that is not to diminish
the story yeah
and it's not like you know they'll take
a quiet break for theme stuff and then
they'll go back to actions it's like
like I said that midpoint sequence where
we're all three war parties are finally
converging and splendid is using her
pregnant belly to to make immortan joe
stay his hand it's like no there it is
there is the smart stuff and the wild
stuff interacting there is the brains
and the guts like you dancing with each
other it doesn't have to be a tag team
it's like a big it's like if a lesser
action movie is is like a tag team of
two dudes like okay there's the kind of
spindle II brainy guy and then up tag
out and here's the burly dude it's like
this movie is more like a big burly dude
who's read a few books like yeah who
knows a few things is and has some
culture about it's like it's the
difference between Bane and poison ivy
from the joel schumacher Batman
interacting with you like one is going
to be like cunning and wily and the
other ones just gonna be like a big
brute yeah it's versus them tag-teaming
you or dark knight rises bane who's
brawny and bringing well yeah and the
cool thing about dark knight rises bane
is that they build up how big he is but
most of what he does that makes a
threatening is what his plans yeah
exactly most of his time hey everyone I
just wanna I just wanna I wish I could
do it better it just do Malcolm McDowell
with your hand over your mouth Oh gross
Tom parties got an interesting work Tom
Hardy has multiple interesting voices
Tom Hardy i think is a great actor
because he's one of those dudes but it's
like even if he looks kind of like him
he can still convince me that he's not
yeah he him he will adopt a new you'll
adopt a new a new kind of like men or
the hidden vocal manner for every
character focal manner and also just
physical mannerisms like he's very like
mr. suave in inception and then he's
something totally different in Bane and
then he's something totally ease up this
slab of meat in this like whacked out
slab of meat in Bronson and in this he's
like you know mangy
junkyard dog in Mad Max mangy a weary
chunkier too sleepy junkyard dog yeah so
if I may oh yeah I'm going to present
Mad Max as and this is my this is rough
this is my me breaking down fury road as
a manual for how to dismantle Patriot
all right okay a movement in three part
yeah tell me that this tell me that this
is not [ __ ] okay first step more or
less um they have to find solidarity
between male allies who have the same
experience of having their agency
stricken that is shown with Mad Max when
they finally meet max who has the muzzle
on his face he has had his agency
stricken from him and they're able to
and there and there's and they're
actively stealing his blood yeah so it's
actively exploiting him for his you know
universal donor hood yeah so it's like
their first you spine you create
solidarity with a male ally who and
against his will to you know I there has
also been aided his skin with needles
and are you sucking the blood ass yeah
so someone who's been imprisoned and in
some way or had their agency stricken or
been in prep oppressed or exploit in his
own way um then you you Ally them with
your calls then you have to work on on
bridging the gap with the guy like nuts
who is an actual like complete complicit
subject end up and in and a participant
in the patriarchal culture in the
greater patriarchal calls or someone who
is invested in toxic masculinity that
you have to take that guy the guy like
nuts and awaken him to can be inherent
corruption yeah that's what happens when
he sees in Morton Joe killed splendid
and lose his chance at glory um then you
okay then you venture forth to make some
kind of contact with the ancient
matriarch matriarchal culture and the
not just the the philosophy and the
knowledge of ancient ancient matriarchal
historical cultures which are you know
the first mothers and the green and the
green place is
so harkening back to the like past
academia in feminism you know it's like
you can read the the first mothers as
kind of symbolizing either or both
alright then you travel back they go
back to the Citadel yeah okay they're
bringing their their male allies and the
matriarchal philosophy and the feminist
philosophy back to the mainstream
patriarchal hegemonic culture that's the
Citadel that's immortan joe's domain
then on the way they're as big towering
phallic rock formations when you when
you when you're reappropriation they
literally rip remember me yeah remember
me they literally rip off important
Joe's mask and what's brilliant is like
when you finally see immortan joe's
quarks what's under the mask just a
bloody pulp yeah there's nothing there
nothing there there's no Jong there's no
jaw there's no mouth it's like literally
saying under his pageantry under his
posturing under his mask there's nothing
[ __ ] there it was all fake well no I
mean his face gets ripped off like yeah
I know in the gear lighting but cuz you
can tell there's when he's screaming
over over her death you can see another
pair of bottom teeth like he's like yeah
you can't see that yeah but when boo
yeah well when everybody else went when
the citizens of the Citadel see immortan
joe's corpse it's like he has he has no
Matt there's just a hole in the bottom
of his faith yeah it's like the yes I'm
were told literally has a mouth that
he's covering up in some capacity but
when you see him on full display dead is
like them the message is being sent
there was nothing under his mask and all
these you know metals and and all this
posturing means nothing yeah here is on
the hood of our car yes like a like a
deer like an ugly dead deer yeah alright
so when you've you know it's like you've
gone back to the hegemonic culture
you've gone back to the patriarchal
culture you've unmasked and revealed the
patriarchal idols in the leaders
to have built their foundations and
their philosophies on nothing there's no
real value system there's just posturing
and pageantry and performative bullship
just preserving your status and
privilege yeah you know then and this is
shown when when um you know when the the
the wet nurse is the first the the wet
nurses the the I guess what's implicitly
the the earlier wives what there you see
them up in what was immortan joe's
balcony now they're up there and they
have the status that in more than Joe
had your now exalting matriarchal and
motherly figures the same way
patriarchal and fatherly figures were a
you know exalted before also in the
process of unmasking immortan joe the
patriarchal figured you are completely
diminishing the myth of like fatherly
ownership you know the whole idea you're
destroying that idea of like my property
say no we're all free people there is no
property and now you're valuing mother
motherhood you're valuing mother figures
and in that process like they get on a
literal lift and they are raised up it's
like in that process you're now feeding
everyone you're nourishing everyone
you're liberating everyone and you are
literally uplifting everyone huh okay
ready to start all right let's go are
you like get the car yes
okay all right wow that's done sick no
more patriarchy I thought hi fabri good
job kid Jabra dude [ __ ] hedge mini yeah
hedging money more like [ __ ] like
[ __ ] money more like ding ding dang
carbonic dank a monic you just wanna be
dang I just want to do one of the kids
we got to create like a [ __ ]
cultural comes a big dent dinky arc
it'll just be a little just like be like
being based yeah d positive stay
positive love each other if everyone
were too dank each other who would be
you oral will be a better place to leave
yeah if ever a la fille shelters in the
world would be a danker place to live oh
there's a movie by a guy who was heard
by my son woman it someplace someone was
not his rose someone was not his rose
and he made a home you should have just
seen fury road instead when it came out
in 2003 yeah so um my max mimic mix mix
mop funky rump and give it him I liked
it I liked you too I like to attend I
liked it at a chance let's see good I
gave it and I liked it out of test I
give it yet no I mean I was just so
through so happy just like fine I was
like there is hope yet for movies for
movies there is hope for like movies hat
won't die on me yet yeah it's just nice
you know it's like there's hope for
action center mothers hope for even
franchise cinema there's hope for you
know progressive cinema Lakers hope for
I was sitting in the theater and the
trailers before madam accident was like
ant-man and Jurassic world and the new
national lampoon vacation movie and and
it was just like I was watching all
these trailers I'm just think
there was one trailer that was for an
original story that was san andreas i'm
justing how sad is this there isn't a
single original story here there's not a
single non reboot non remake non
adaptation except for san andreas which
is just big disaster movie gonna be the
best rock good team oh but there is
quite far too yeah I was just thinking
well I mean I'm here for a franchise
movie and then I saw him I saw the
franchise movie that gained their form
like good franchise well yeah I mean
again it is sound like a broken record
but it's all about approach it's like
you just got to take the right approach
it's like they wait until they had the
right story and they waited like you
know it's like everything that makes
this movie good is something that they
really seemed to have the right approach
on it's like how do we how do we make
the action as as stunning and beautiful
and thrilling and sort of symphonic as
possible well let's see how much this we
can actually put on screen and then
would use our CG smartly how can we make
you know how can we keep this this world
in this story going well we'll just come
back when we have something to say you
know it's you know how can we make this
interesting and different well maybe we
can bring in you know a more progressive
undertone to the story and then go and
consult and talk to the authorities on
the because I talked to I think a few
people okay good sculpting the sort of
limbo under the most astronomers
high-profile person I've heard of was
Eve Ensler yeah the woman who compiled
the vagina mom yeah but I that again
don't quote me but I think they I think
they talked to a few people okay um cuz
if there was more than just her and
fantastic yeah and I mean you know it
just seems like every every part of this
was just approached the proper way and
also you know George Miller owns mad Mac
so he can do with it what he wants you
know that's art in the hands of the
artist that made it you know it's and
they had you know they had WB money but
like it's crazy that you know I've never
I've never been someone that was like
super hot for auteur theory but i think
this is one of those things that
sometimes it's
good too it's good too if you're going
to revisit a property or an idea or
story it's good to do it under the guise
or do it under the banner of the person
that created it who kind of can
holistically unify everything under what
what it was always meant to mean in a
broader scope yeah and I mean this is
this is a very distinct world too I mean
this is this is sort of it's probably
less distinct because it's been hearken
to so much with like you know especially
in video game world like fallout and
borderlands and everything yeah yeah for
sure but you know they all have to tip
their hat to Mad Max as being the thing
that's set it up for them well yeah this
is the kind of movie that is distinctive
and wild and sort of like it from the
very moment Mad Max became a thing it
has been distinct yeah and that's all
that you know cuz like yeah at or theory
is a problem you know everything in
moderation at the end of the day it's
like no this is an instance where that
really works yeah you know this guy
clearly knows what he's doing in his
world and he brought on collaborators
that that really helps things out yeah
exact I wasn't like you know it wasn't
like ha Ridley Scott decided he's going
to trust his alien prequel to Damon
Lindelof ok damn it kuwait I'm not a
Damon Lindelof exper I just know that
whatever his name is mentioned people
are like oh cuz I this is I think Damon
Lindelof is at the core of like the prom
with the lobby JJ Abrams properties were
just like you you can set up the mystery
like everything that Damon Lindelof
touches makes for a better trailer but
can't hold together as a complete story
yeah well cuz i was a part like tomorrow
Lane came out this week and I didn't
even know he worked on that but now but
everyone's thing anybody who's not
psyched out on tomorrow Lana's is going
linda la playa well I was like cursing
Lindelof when I saw Prometheus cuz I was
like it what and that that like see the
thing is I'm still learning it what
makes it him versus cuz like a lot of
the movies he's written he's co-written
or high or had a credit on yeah and like
a face it said that he comes in for
they'll get him a lot of times to fix
third
max except huh he doesn't fix that I
guess I don't know it's just like you
know maybe there's some there probably
is something greater at play here yeah
if I'd asked you for all you know this
guy get so much work if he if he [ __ ]
somebody thinks it's like it's almost
like it they only hire Damon Lindelof to
fix things that are already kind of
doomed it seems like yeah but everything
I heard secondhand about like earlier
drafts of Prometheus were that they were
better before Lindelof showed up yes
well I don't know maybe it is him maybe
it's not him I don't know I don't want
to like talk [ __ ] about the guy I don't
know him I don't know his work yeah I
don't like it's like always his work is
always like one of many names yeah yeah
he's always a collaborator on stuff and
I'm just having trouble understanding
because it seems like he somehow gets a
lot of really high profile work on
things that end up being sort of
debatable hmm like highly successful but
also highly debatable it's also like you
guys who wrote the i think it was like
the second transformers movie they're
also the same two guys that meant and or
see ya they're also apparently the same
guys that wrote the first there the the
first JJ r star trek movie which people
like so it's like those yeah those dudes
are like sometimes those dudes will show
up for some [ __ ] and sometimes I'll
show up for something pretty cool like
no one knows what to make heads or tails
of it yeah maybe it's just the JJ Abrams
demands more of them than Michael Bay
does no cuz it's weird man like and when
comes the Damon Lindelof is like
everything that he touches seems to make
like a great trailer but a bad movie and
I heard some I saw it tweet I saw I saw
a tweet it's all a tweet home school it
seems like Damon Lindelof shows up
whenever whenever there's like here's
something kind of interesting and and
and sort of you know sci-fi and also
it's not working oh yeah let me see who
was it a guy named scout at NYC SC 0 UT
he said tomorrow land Prometheus star
trek into darkness cowboys vs aliens
Damon Lindelof is the PT Barnum of
movies huh
Oh God yeah which it kind of makes sense
it's like every damon lindelof penned
movie seems to start with like a trailer
that's like the roadside billboard for
come see the world's biggest ball of
yarn and then you actually sit down see
the movie and you have the experience
and it's only like two feet wide it's a
[ __ ] ball yarn it's not that
astounding well for me this is
especially maddening yeah Prometheus
goes check out all these ideas and then
it ends on we're gonna figure that on
part two yeah it's like the move it's
like the one the very last wise and
prometheus is I'm gonna go looking for
answers it's like don't bother he
answers we came to this movie for you
might not even make that movie now like
yeah give me at least one it's like and
it's like it sets up this question of
what would happen if we found out that
we were created by these highly advanced
alien genetic engineers what would
happen if we met our creators and it
answers that with those those good scary
monsters yeah it's like they're just hey
they're just gonna get up and punch us a
lot yeah it was like a little space
jockey thing it was like reading some
kids english homework where he had to
write a short story and he set up a plot
and then when everyone finally got the
car to go have the plot it's like aliens
came and killed everyone yeah yeah bit
yeah I mean that's oh that movie is like
it keeps teasing you with ideas and then
keeps drowning that in like I don't know
this guys getting attacked it looks like
it shows the proto the prototype of the
xenomorph at the end it's like I don't
give a [ __ ] where the xenomorph comes
from especially now especially now you
set up like you're gonna talk about
bigger ideas than where the [ __ ]
xenomorph came from now it's just you're
giving me this franchise masturbation
well yeah it's like they spent the whole
pre-emptive part being like no no it's
just in the alien universe but it has
almost nothing to do with that and then
it's like well great and now we're
ending and the biggest moment you've
given me is like hey the thing from
alien that we said wasn't the point but
now sort of is you what did why did you
build all that [ __ ] up for an hour like
the first half of the
I was really widget now it's like a is a
cool moment or two no no damn it also
seems like strange cat hmm at least in
terms of his writing no no so I'm glad
he didn't pen fury yeah sure I'm saying
fury road again I've never been it's
like I have never been dissatisfied this
excited to go see a summer tentpole
movie before yeah right I was
tentatively interested in the dark
knight rises I liked it and it didn't
age well with me I you know I see its
problems really clearly now I'm I still
kind of hold Nolan's Batman movies I
mean granted you know so they're
problematic in ways I still think
there's more going on and more care and
effort put into those than a lot of the
stuff that gets churned out of the
machine yeah I mean they I think they
least took a distinct approach in and
model the world after that I mean they
not that they aren't bogged down by
certain things but they're better to me
and it's like you know it you see man of
steel and everyone's like oh you know
personal worked on this too but only
cursorily yeah and you feel that it's
like there's something about the way
those movies play out that still feels a
bit more substantial to me than yeah you
know the constant churn and those movies
also I admire what he did in the sense
that he did take his I get it's like I
think he took the right approach it
leaves even if Nolan is a filmmaker who
sort of has these sophisticated
aspirations and like a thoughtful i but
doesn't always have the the the skill
enough to pay off the deeper ideas and
the bigger things like the thing is he
can handle the he can handle the deeper
ideas when he really simplifies them
like an inception yeah inception the
philosophy was very simple it was just
like a matter of juggling the different
layers that that the plot was going
through this simple philosophy wrapped
in very intricate you know intricate
traveling I think the hot the problems
with the Dark Knight trilogy may stand
mostly from David Goyer what's possible
I get that vibe dick every movie I've
seen that's just written by David Goyer
has not not been excellent such as
fortunate should I just like be
uninvited and he did look up some of it
David Goyer joints cuz yeah it's like I
have I've sort of learned to have more
faith in David Goyer as a collaborator
than as a as a sole writer and captain
of the ship yeah exactly like was man of
steel just him now there's no story
credit um oh no he wrote it yeah he
wrote man of steel oh yeah you did right
man soon and it's like man of steel is
like the first half is cool like the
first half I like the sort of like
actually playing with like the he's an
alien like the alien alienation and then
some of the darker ideas but it's that's
about as close as it gets you know with
that movie um it's like I'm in the
second half it just devolves into we're
punching each other a lot jumper jumper
your glitter jumper um hero hood blown
three all three of the blade movies huh
city don't sit don't seem very good man
Turks I mean it'sit's you're not super
story crazy yeah and alex proyas also
has a screenplay better yeah see I think
he's a better collaborator than that I
saw hero crow city I didn't see positive
in georgia southern region I'd only seen
the crew Oh kickboxer too yeah I don't
know I feel like David Goyer may be a
better collaborator collabo or at least
you know a better garnish you should
collaborate with Tyler the Creator yeah
the end for that was the one was the
unborn good bad no different
borges got a kooky um yeah I mean that
and that's certainly certainly a
possibility and I know that there's even
a difference between Chris and and
Jonathan Nolan cuz you know that like
Jonathan Nolan was the writer on memento
yeah yeah yeah and I mean there's been
stuff brought up as to UM like the
ending of transcendence interstellar
like his ending was different than thank
Chris Christopher knowing things only
that so I and I think his ending was
supposed to be darker or something like
that something Jonathan known is a bit
more of the darker side of that you know
yin yang why can't I find you a giant
Jonathan with an H nothing without me is
it just janitor or or even John yeah
that's moment I can't type on this is
this is the rhythm riveting google it
love it haha you're spelling it like
that I know I morrell that yeah the new
he worked on the the new West world HBO
miniseries which I'm interested in yeah
too I mean West worlds of core that
seems like it is really it looks really
gorgeous I haven't seen him providing
firmly oh I saw some promos okay at an
event was it coming no is it it was a it
was a talk that Mike Lombardo the
President of Programming of HBO did at
UCLA hey man HBO is Rios on their shirts
not TV yeah HBO's on her [ __ ] and
they've been producing some really heavy
documentaries like yeah like I am had to
see all the time so he's a mob montage a
peck yes I wanted montage effect that
really late it was you know it's a
portrait it's not like narrative yeah
well I mean montage of heck is like a
mood piece that's peppered with you know
there are a few interviews here and
there but it's really like it'sit's yet
it's a very
pressive it's very dissonant and it sort
of just is a portrait yeah it's too bad
that what it is Kurt Cobain would feel
wide yet is too bad they didn't get um
so that they weren't able to get um Dave
Grohl Dave Grohl's interviews in the
movie and time there was a scheduling
conflict so I was like his interviews
were recorded after most of the moves
cut together so I was so I was told yeah
I was there too there's like special
bonus features out there for the DVD of
Dave Grohl's two cents yeah I'd love to
see that too cuz like I was it it was
weird not having him there but in a
sense and this my proportion but in a
sense it was almost like cuz Dave girl
is such an entity now yeah to not have
him was almost he's not like the others
not just another one of you ladies at
her I know what does he say your plays
either for ten days yeah he'll never say
what what would you say if he'd never
show me what why'd you have to go
fighting send alies she said everything
you said you gotta promise not to step
right so let me keep recordings I was
gonna you know it's impossible no no no
is he selling you out are you getting
the best the best the best of the best
of me this is my goods just you he'll
sit and watch your every move it's like
it's nice because it's like on the one
hand it's kind of like he doesn't
overshadow things because he's so
ubiquitously oh he's a favorite role as
Dave Grohl and he's all over the place
and he's kinda you know like big an
entity on the landscape mmm Leah montage
of heck was something else and then like
you know I watched the jinx ahaha watch
the jinx is pretty heavy and like a
little want to watch an old guy burp a
lot he dude you never realized how
creepy by but like people people say bye
bye past a certain age Leah and when you
hear this like this leg eerily calm
older chap say bye bye so many times on
the phone it really gets on you
this very straight it's a fascinating
story it's a it's a very jarring
documentary and if what they got is
authentic that's they they gained it a
little bit oh they gained in the
presentation a little bit cuz cuz there
there's motor to one yeah but I mean
that was that was that was heavy there's
another one on the Grim Sleeper or
whatever that horrid I should again is
very heavy and will make you very upset
yeah but uh has been recommended to me
they're there Nancy Mimi sage green jr.
um I have an opinion on um on um going
clear I may or may not have seen it oh
that's all I'm glad I will I may or may
not have seen going clear and I may or
may not have an opinion that is positive
and or negative about it but I will
repulse stating any of that for fear of
retaliation from the Church of
Scientology and board of directors are
you a sight huh no no I really like to
go and clear oh yeah there there there
are more things I would have wanted out
of it but I like what I got out of it
yeah I've heard that of her debts that
spoken to yeah a couple times although I
mean there were three things are cuddly
dance there were things I got out of it
I had no it I had no realization that
anyone could have gotten ahold of that
yeah what what would you have liked or
do you um I was not wanna go on record I
I would have liked to have seen their
take on certain things in the indeed
history of Scientology like um I think
operation clambake it was called things
like Lisa McPherson Lisa mcpherson KS um
different different um kind of spooky
things that are historically tied to the
church of scientology i would have been
interested to see those portrayed um
then i may be getting operation clambake
wrong there may be the wrong name for
what the event I'm thinking of was and
it may be the
they make it may that may be the name of
something to actually do covered the
documentary on ella misma 60 operation
clambake just yeah it's like Elvis isn't
it's like a secret agent but also he's
any note I'm to the beach he's a he's a
secret agent that is on a case in Hawaii
because such season Hawaii is easily new
and he has to win a surf competition
yeah he's undercover as a singing
surfboard guy yeah at the big clam bake
um no it's and I would have liked to
have seen some that but things like you
know intricate into intimate portrayals
of l ron hubbard during his time on the
ocean things like that that english
interview with l ron hubbard where he
looks like he is strung out things like
the the the request for psychiatric
treatment from the VA hospital let's see
like those things were fascinated well
and insane to me that they could get
ahold of that kind of stuff yes sir so
on that kind of just in a broad waist
with shows like the alley I get why you
use so hate psychiatry yeah cuz it's
like it just seems like ones petty
things it's like oh I can connect the
dots it's like oh you were denied this
you must hate it like so we we covered
fury road we did cover fear we killed
the patriarchy kill the Patriot um I
think I think we did well we're
sufficiently day we covered Damon
Lindelof and and blur and yeah we did
cover Blair fan in there and magic whip
go by HBO docks uh go see some HBO dogs
go see fury road multiple times I'm
gonna have to see it multiple times you
pay for that [ __ ] like hey money to see
fury road this is Susie quits your
dollars it does not have to be in this
is crazy thing they've already greenlit
sequels even though it has not made back
150 million budget worldwide yet it was
it should world yes like worldwide they
they had that whole like box office
[ __ ] about like oh you know pitch
perfect 2 is making so much
more money than man Maggs but at the end
of the weekend they were like hey Mad
Max overperformed and B if you look at
the the worldwide they were pretty much
like it was still like honored it's also
mad mad max he made a little mad Max's
are ya pretty hard to Mad Max is a hard
R so it's like for a hard R movie it did
really well yes what I mean you know
because I was having this conversation
with somebody and they were surprised
that that you know pitch perfect
outperformed at least in America and is
not really that surprising to me because
it's like you you have more
family-friendly pg-13 recent franchise
sequel acapellas very popular versus
this sort of crazy post-apocalyptic
thing from 30 years ago yeah you know
that's that's back now and is for adults
only yeah ostensibly yeah and you know
looks imposing yeah it's well it's like
everything is painted in fire and rust
everything is yellow except for suddenly
everything is blue at night why they did
day for night and then that was very
that was a conscious decision I read cuz
he's on record a few times saying like
yeah you know all these post-apocalyptic
movies the the instinct is to desaturate
everything and make everything look kind
of monochromatic so we decided to do the
opposite and really make the colors rich
you know what I love that is beautiful
one it makes the air more dense yeah
there looks like it's filled with
noxious rust particles yeah so you saw
and it's you know again that Symphony
metaphor it's like you know you have
different colors to go along with
different movements and so you'll have
these things that are orange and brown
and red and then at night it's very blue
when things are you know more serene or
more quiet you know and they they they
decided to to go day for night for the
shot I mean that's fine because like
it's in a post-apocalyptic desert so
it's like when the sun's out there is no
illumination yeah and so you know they
wanted that light I guess they and you
know having it be so blue after it is so
orange is a really cool really different
from now yeah in a visual style and
according to them on the blu-ray there
to put a black and white black and white
edition which and that's you know again
he touched on that tues like you know I
kind of want this to be black and white
but since you know paagal do is just so
washed out and all I mean white has been
relegated to art films in the modern age
you know we hyper saturated but you know
I still love the version that's in black
and whites are gonna put that in the DVD
you know so it's awesome I've also heard
I don't know if this is true but serisa
there's gonna be a silent version yeah I
mean it could work cuz it's like you
know it's it's a story told so much with
physical action so it's like you
apparently I mean I've read some words
like George Miller took some notes from
from silent cinema and how that works
and like yet good but casual sporty
visual stories doing I mean you know cuz
like I as a writer like I like dialogue
I like to write lots of dialogue but you
know there are bits of dialogue that I
think really work and really are
serviceable like things like you know
not enough saying we are not to blame
and sponging didn't who killed the world
and you know the it's like the dialogue
is specific and it goes you know goes
back to something I remember you know
being told in screenwriting school which
I went to um I have an MFA instrument
heading for all the listeners out there
um I remember it was like one professor
told me it's like the other thing about
39 is that it's kind of like any didn't
mean this in a web highfalutin or or uh
or potential is this from uniting is
comic pochard your have to you have to
get the most out with the least words
you have to get everything out through
Condon can condensed language-specific
condensed language they really took that
yeah won't even this stuff like you know
they're they're always speeches and
things like that in a lot of our modern
action fodder and I thought even those
adventures yeah yeah it's like people
will take breaks to deliver arouse like
rousing address listen everybody I know
it seems hopeless now because this is
the dark night of the soul sequence at
the end of the second act going into the
third act but we are the avengers age of
ultron yeah
we are going to defeat Ultron his ages
12 he's 12 years old today is his
birthday his name's kids today yes and
like even the little speech email it's
like there are ways to make that looks
like that demo more he says like you
know hey don't give him hope you know
cuz can't fix something we go nuts you
know it's like you know that moment was
earned and like that little piece of
philosophy I didn't mean to me a 20
minute monologue it was just a few lines
but you know that's that's true that guy
yes it's true to people the fact like
people people don't state their their
personal phone like if someone's just
going to state their personal philosophy
as an anecdote or as a piece of advice
they're going to give it in just a
sentence as like a rote fact or a bit of
wisdom people don't like trying this
bowser philosophy in a 20-minute speech
to set it up to somebody unless they're
you know under very specific
circumstances yeah exactly yeah so mad
max making fat stacks hopefully
hopefully so one would hope and now i
just hope that they continue yeah you
know qualitatively i mean apparently
there was a plan for a sequel after this
called just mad max fury oh so so i'm
down to see an ongoing Mad Max and
furiosus story a BPA cuz it's like I was
thinking you know the way that was
playing out it was almost like it's like
Max and furios that are like the parents
of the new world that's going to arise
out this apocalypse yeah and I was so
down for that they're kind of the
spiritual parents for what everything
for what's going to that between the two
then they gave birth to everything
that's going to kind of regenerate this
world yeah not to diminish the actual
you know the the women that are actually
moms well I don't you I mean that's you
know that's that's a that's a different
you know it's busy my max he is
instrumental he's just not the only
instrumental somebody a friend of mine
sort of described as like I'm just sort
of took it as like it's it's a love
story but
it's down below stood it's like a love
story doesn't love because like it's
about two people learning that they are
kind of fighting similar fights there's
sort of kindred spirits like they match
like your they're not in love there's no
romance there but they learn to trust
and rely on each other and that they
have they got they have a depth of
relationship and a depth of church that
I don't wanna say it's deeper than then
a romantic relationship but no you no
way it kind of is because it's like
they're it's meaningful it's like yes
it's incredibly meaningful yeah hell
yeah yeah what a dainik and now sig was
going to be a magic on this I was musket
likes structured like a romantic Tom did
the fact that there was like mid point
sequence when they finally learned to
work together yeah and then he he he
motorcycles to the airport just like
don't go in the in the dust storm
instead of rain yeah that does storm the
debt dost dead does there five applause
breaks really the first time it was the
first time I tried to start an applause
break and nobody was going for ads there
was [ __ ] uh and then there was finally
in a pause break at the end of the movie
okay yeah there was a pause break the
ensberg safe first the first time there
was a lot of like oh yeah cuz I mean I I
feel like I saw with a few like repeat
viewers yeah you're always Melling
second time yeah hell yeah yeah all
right and one of the kids stayed a tank
stay